hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of the witching hour
I am Perri Nemiroff that's Halley fetch
but we got to get those introductions
out of the way because we have Gary
Doberman in studio right now we are
feature directorial debut Annabelle
comes home and not even gonna bother to
list off the whole bunch of other
projects that we greatly admire that
you've worked on so say Annabelle comes
over now well I'll say it well I just so
you guys know I haven't seen Annabelle
comes home yet Haley has so we're coming
at it from that approach right now but
I'll throw in Annabelle creation because
I movie we wanted to start a little by
getting a sense of how you got into the
industry to begin with because usually I
like to look up you know everybody's
gateways you filmmaking and I couldn't
find anything on you wonder why that is
yeah I don't have any social media or
anything you know I moved out here 2002
I you know I just I wanted to write I
wanted to make movies and I moved out
and did none of those things I just
cater waiter Dan dice
you know waited tables I bar attended
and then I you know I interned in a lot
of places and I you know one of the the
places I ended up was with a woman named
Catherine James who managed Quentin
Tarantino very early on and larger Avery
and those guys and I got a good sense of
what the writing life was like through
her and then you know but that took you
know doing that and then writing and
then and then and then I would your
bartender or when I say Barton I mean
more like [ __ ] like busboy or
something at night and then I would go
home and I'd write a little bit but he
got you know it was just I wasn't
getting a lot of writing done so I took
time off and you know
saved up you know a couple hundred bucks
really took a month off wrote a spec and
that was really what got my you know
what got the attention of agents and the
Studios and stuff like that it was a
spec called death County which is very
much my love letter to John Carpenter
and big trouble little China and you
know I said love letter was a thought it
was just a complete ripoff of Big
Trouble in Little China but I still love
this I still love the script and and
yeah that just got me my agent that got
me the studio stuff and then from there
I was kind of you own people's radars
other were and then I started to do
sci-fi movies so they would write so
this one sci-fi channel was doing this
Saturday night maybe they still are but
they were doing these Saturday night
movies and they had you know they would
they would come to me they're like hey
we have a title we have a cast we have a
location we have a director we really
need a script because it would be
shooting a week and a half so we take
the week and I take a couple days and I
would bang out a script you know using
the guidelines like the locations and
all that stuff and I would just write I
would write a script is the ultimate
boot camp it's very much like the Roger
I felt to me like with the ROG and
quorum and without you know Nate
Nicholson or anything but it was just it
was just me so it was very much it
really was a great way to sort of build
that muscle of writing something very
very quickly and you know and then
seeing what it was like through
production and scenes what would it when
someone takes your words and I haven't
seen any of those movies but you know
the scripts I've you know but but yeah
so that's what started and then from
there you start to get you know more and
more notice and people start to you know
bring you in on more meetings and from
there it's you know was it always that
or did you ever say when you are a kid I
want to be like a firefighter when I
grow up
ya know know is never a firefighter I
you know very you know okay I'll take
you through that like when I was a kid
everyone Disney animator was way into
animation I loved all that stuff when we
talked about this frequently where
there's like every single horror
filmmaker we talked to it's you know the
evil sinister side that comes out
through the movies but then there's like
a sweetness to it so I hear does Hannum
and I have toys story for running
through my veins right now and I think
all of the Americans I could have and I
I think of it and having just seen
Annabelle come home I think I I don't
know I see like an animation influence
and son of some of your staging could
help that there's a doll and I love
those moments in Toy Story for this
there's the you know there was really
some tense scary moments in which I
really dug but yeah sorry yeah no I
wanted to be Disney animator I got very
very much into comic books Tim Burton's
Batman was a huge influence on me as a
kid you know raised lost our little my
favorite movies but you know then I went
from Disney animated be when I wanted to
be Todd McFarlane I wanted to be Gimli I
want to be these guys at image comic
book you know and all Neal Adams and but
I learned pretty pretty quickly I was
not up to snuff when it came to the the
art side of things but you know and then
you know I talked to a lot of you know
horror filmmakers and stuff and they
always talk about well I get my friends
over or we get fake blood and we make
these little short movies and I just
didn't have that so what I had was a was
a well you know I had I had a pen and
paper and I had you know computers and
stuff and I would just so that's what
really kind of writing was was
accessible and it was free and it was a
lot of money involved so and I you know
I worship you know from a very early age
I really loved at ground PO you know
Christopher Pike RL Stein and then of
course Stephen King and all those like I
just really love that that those those
stories and stuff so that's what really
got me into writing and things it was
really the one thing I was okay because
I was terrible and everything else
math science sports like there was
nothing I really excelled at and riding
was one of the things like this is not
this doesn't feel so challenging or so
you know I just I bet I enjoyed it it
was one of those things that I just I
really I really enjoyed and just would
do one of my free time as opposed you
know I mean I mean you kind of look for
those things like what am i doing on my
free time and yeah so I was like oh this
is this is one of those things I want to
do
so you you had your sci-fi bootcamp you
got your you know your feet what you
wrote a spec based on big trouble one of
my favorite films design me too how did
you get involved with new line in the
conjuring universe because you have set
up like a very seems a very happy
symbiotic relationship there where
you're you continue to work in that
universe or with it with new line how
did that relationship develop you know
new line it brought me in for for a
roundtable a great guy named Gary King
read a script of mine called burst that
another spec I wrote that I love which
is you know people stranded in a
snowstorm and one by one they just
started spontaneously combusting know
which is another spec I hope see just I
really love that story so he but he read
that and brought me in for they were
doing a round table and Nightmare on Elm
Street
the reboot after that I got made and
they were gonna do some you know
additional stuff on it and I did some so
that everybody through that wall Hamada
Dave Neustadter they like mentors to me
they they brought me in and and you know
I helped them out on that and then from
there we just we did a couple other
scripts and that we really got the sort
of the ball rolling and in terms of the
new line of it all but it's like you
know you find your village you find your
people and you kind of want to work with
them as much as you can as long as you
guys are getting along it's it's that's
that's kinda how I look at it you know
you get to you know you choose to
project but you also when you're
choosing the project you're also
choosing the people that you're gonna be
in the in the you know the foxhole with
throughout this whole process so you
want to be make sure you with the right
people that was a lesson I you know I
just I learned pretty quickly like you
need to find the right people and then
fortunately they've been the right
people for a pretty long time and if
you're looking to tap into horror legacy
you can't even with that it feels like
you guys had to find your footing at
least because I was like one of the
biggest conjuring fans in the world it
was my favorite movie of 2013 and then
admittedly I didn't love Annabelle but
then you guys turned it around
incredibly well with Annabelle
creational II to a point that I was not
expecting and I'm like oh they got this
they're gonna run with it so I'm just
curious from your perspective what is it
like after conjuring to have Annabelle
come out and maybe the reactions not be
as hot and then what's going through
your head in order to get things done
quite like you did it with creation cuz
I was so impressed by the turnaround
thank you
you know I'll say you know yes the the
critical reaction to Annabelle is not
great but I can t look if I've you know
that's something I can you know however
it is very very well at the box office
right so but yeah you it's it's you are
learning you you know you're it is an
education as you're as you're going
forward but I don't my education does
not involve me listening to the critics
and going like oh it's not as if they're
telling me anything I like it's not like
oh yeah no you're right you know it's
not surprising when these things come
out where it feels it gets a little bit
of a like a backseat driver so a
situation but but it wasn't but but you
just kind of we took time to store we
step back you know we you know Sandburg
came in and you know he's a great talent
but you know we learned on Annabelle and
I you know I don't really you know I you
know just a fun experience making that
movie
Leonetti was so gracious and generous
letting me be on set so that was really
and he really set the tone for all the
other movies in the you know in terms of
like that collaborative environment he
working with James Wan and all that
stuff which is which I think is
something I personally got an
environment I really thrive in which is
a collaborative sort of back and forth
conversation that I like they just put
two and two together that you two had
worked together which that
well Satori didn't you know something
else
the first Annabelle as well yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that was another one
we're just you're just kind of trying
things out and again it felt very I
don't want to say like it felt like the
Corman but it was just like hey let's
just try this and see if it works and if
it doesn't it's not a huge investment we
can you know we can we can sort of move
on so it's yeah it's been an education
it's been an experience but I think
fortunately we're getting better with
each one absolutely it's not easy this
day and age to put together a great
cinematic universe it feels like so many
out there have tried and failed but
you guys seem to be getting better with
every single installment awesome I hope
so I hope so and yeah I think I think we
you know you sort of take what you learn
you carry it forward but yeah it's and
again what's finding the right people to
work with and all that stuff it really
helps so how far back in that process
because you depend with it for a long
time you know I did the sort of seed of
this idea for Annabelle comes home and
this sort of like team-up of some of the
greatest from the franchise some new
characters and unleashing them all in
one film sort of come about I will say
not too far back I think when we do
pride ourselves on this universe is not
thinking too far ahead of ourselves
because I you know I think it's a fool's
errand and we kind of think of what
movie we're working on in the moment so
it's really you know animal creations
done people seem to really respond to it
it's hard not to go okay well what's
next and then James had this great idea
of hey what would it be like to bring in
the doll and the presence of the other
other artifacts room you know we see
this room and so many other movies it'd
be really great to explore it for for
for a movie and that's a that's an idea
that really I really sparked to because
I couldn't think of I mean you know if I
sat in a room long enough maybe I could
but I couldn't think of you know we sort
of talked about the mythology of the
doll and creation I don't want to go you
know you don't want to make it's you
know so big so in this one I really
wanted I thought like oh if we do that
then it's an organic way to really talk
about somebody I want to or explore
somebody I had been thinking about which
is Judy Warren and what it would be like
to be the daughter of Edmund rain Warren
these paranormal investigators and grow
up in a house with this room of you know
haunted cursed evil objects so I thought
that was a cool way in and a cool
opportunity to you know to really just
kind of dig into and explore and how
soon after that did you decide that you
wanted to direct and all that came
together that was early on too I was
writing to direct I knew we knew very
early on in the in the process I was
gonna direct and that was it just felt
like a natural progression because I had
been on the other movies on the sets and
you know through prep and production
and post and so I you know I I could go
in a little bit more wide-eyed knowing
sort of the challenges that present
themselves when you're directing and not
be so caught off guard with things so it
just was a really just part of the
conversation because thy name is Ben Roy
he's looking around for who's gonna who
do we think could could direct this and
all that and it just you know the you
know the you know I just every all eyes
came to me and what about you and yeah
what about me so so yeah so from there
it was just you know then then I you
know that was I wrote the script knowing
that I was going to be the one who had
to do something with it to it with all
the confidence or did you need like a
pep talk from anybody that you know now
you were ready to direct a feature film
no you know no you know it was it was
yeah there were certainly some pepto you
know oh my god guys but yeah there were
certainly some pep talks of course you
know everybody's always so supportive
and so encouraging but from the writing
side of it it wasn't like it was also it
was said you should put a lot of love in
the script and there was a lot of
shorthand there because I knew I was
gonna be the one who was gonna so I was
able I knew you know I knew I kind of
knew who my DP was going be so I could
call him up I could call you know James
was there so it was I was I could I
could really I wanted to get the script
out I wanted story down and then get
into the prep quickly so we knew it so I
can get ahead of some challenges that
normally sometimes when you're writing
you're going I really hope they're
they'll have the money or the half the
time or they'll have the wherewithal to
really pull this off and on this one I
could get ahead of that without the
fingers crossed part of it because I
could get hey do we have the time money
and we're thought to pull this up yes
okay great I'll write it in you know so
that was that was nice and that was you
know that was an advantage I could use
did you have to know from the very
beginning when you first started writing
it that you had Vera Farmiga and Patrick
Wilson involved because maybe this is
just how my brain has been
compartmentalizing things since the very
beginning but I'm like oh they are just
like the main Condor ant conjuring
franchise and then everything else is
with new cast members right no I you
know was their version without
them I think yeah we could have made
that happen for sure but it just felt
what I like about having well you know
other than it being Patrick and vir and
they're fantastic and they really ground
you know I think ed in the rain really
ground the series and and and they're
sort of the heart and soul of the series
but you know knowing that I was gonna be
set at the warren house and in the
artifact room it felt like an organic
way to to have them in bringing them
into the animal franchise as opposed to
starting with how can we get and how can
we get the you know ed and Lorraine into
the franchise we didn't we didn't we
didn't look at it like that it was more
like oh we can bring them in and you
know fortunately you know patch it can
veer they respond to the script and
there's such great partners in this and
yeah it was just it was just it was you
know I had seen I'd seen the conjuring
very early on and in such a you know I
tell people it's such a you know I think
we've talked about this I think it's you
know it's rare when you're watching a
movie going like oh my god this is gonna
be some of my kids watch for 20 years
from now and I feel that way about the
conjuring I really do think it's it's a
like it was one of those kind of instant
classics for me so to see them walk on
set of Annabelle comes home and they add
in the rain you know Patrick with the
sideburns and vier with the great hair
and shawl or whatever she's wearing was
a real sort of you know unforgettable
moment for me it was really a really
cool experience taking a cue from what
James started with the first conjuring
movie what is it like going in to this
new movie with that new line like visual
style in mind because there's been a
couple of like repetitive things from
film to film that feels like it unites
the franchise in a way that I really
like so is there any things that you
know James or any other director for
that matter did on some of the other
films that you kind of wanted to add to
yours well I just I love the James Bond
aesthetic I mean it's just the guys
always he was a huge influence me before
I worked with them I I had seen a very
very early screening of saw at the
ArcLight in Hollywood where he and Lee
came out and do like a QA you know just
as a fan I was I was I was oh wait you
know I just I just I just loved him so
I've always so he's only was a big
influence on me before I worked with
them you know I don't know what but so I
think I just kind of I hope I I sort of
took some of that influence and used it
in this movie
he likes his blacks black like I do I
don't know huge fan of that movie that
movie that you know movie darkness where
everything's sort of blueish you know
why you have to do that you got to have
it but you know I think about like you
know in the first conscience when you
know
Lorraine's in the basement striking
those matches and you know and Leonetti
was DP on that and it's just such a
fantastic job of just using the that
that that matchstick to really like
that's the stuff that really you know I
loved and I tried to do that a little
bit on this one you know where I could
just to get those pools of blackness
because anything can be lurking with it
they're cranking shot through the house
with that and then also the the stairway
flip you gotta be careful just Warner's
there's a lot of people you know and
then let's do one and then let's not do
it isn't what's simple it's chop it up
and get some coverage something I really
loved though it does it has the one or
it has signature conjuring verse
elements to it but this very much
Annabelle comes home feels like in an
evolution of sorts for the franchise it
has a different sort of tone a lighter
tone it has a different visual style
very colorful you bring a lot of energy
and punch to the visuals that's
obviously something that James Wan does
as well but you do it in a very
different way I'm curious
was that a concern at all because the
brand has so far been pretty like very
serious films and this is a much lighter
I haven't said yet I really love this
movie laughing you really knocked it out
thanks so much
was that ever a concern to take it in a
lighter more colorful direction was it
ever concern I think it was talked about
but I don't I don't think it was talked
about and sort of a concerning I just
they you know look I think they known me
for years they know my sensibilities you
know I'm a cha the 80s I love the Amblin
style you know I just love look
like you know if we can get people
laughing in one scene and I'm getting
scared in the next scene like that to me
is a perfect little movie moment there
so these are my sensibilities and they
really you know I think they all
embraced it very very early on you know
there was the Bob character that was I
brought in really really early on that
that was the main point of discussion
[Music]
[Laughter]
was talked about nothing no no he's
gonna meet this guy this guy you know
but so no it wasn't ya was it wasn't
really a concern and I wanted to do
something just personally just for me
that felt a little bit different from
like how can we make this you know I'm
not expanding let mythology the doll
like how can we make this a little bit
different just so it doesn't feel like
yeah we're doing the same thing over and
over again in this movie for a lot of
like from me this movie and working on
it was it was you know it was a comfort
food or something I just you know the
year prior spent a couple months in
Romania on the set of the nun which is
like you know I love Transylvania it's
beautiful and all that stuff but you
know being away from my wife and my kids
and you know it's like there's no easy
flight back you know you're just you
getting you get really really homesick
so this was a very much a homecoming for
me as well you know and I wanted to get
back to a little bit more of the
traditionals I you know I love creaky
floorboards I love rocking chair I love
that you know I know it's you know it's
it's sort of trophy but you know for me
I just I dig that stuff so I wanted to I
wanted to bring that back too and all
that I feel like a lot of the franchise
has a classic vibe and I don't know
maybe that maybe that's part of the
reason why I take to it so much usually
when you have I don't know three movies
if not more in a single franchise you
see certain elements get updated with
every single installment so the look at
the Annabelle doll seems like it's the
same but is there anything about the
doll you got to work with on this movie
that was drastically different from the
very beginning no I didn't wanna yeah we
you know each filmmaker has done a
little bit differently from designed it
a little bit differently than how it was
introduced in the first conjuring I went
back to closely to the first conjuring
just because we pick up with that where
the opening of the conjuring you go
so I didn't want it to be too much of a
difference but beyond that I mean it's
it's it's one of those things where
people have such an intense reaction to
just to seeing her that it feels feel
somehow misguided to go a little bit
like you know no no I'm gonna put my own
spin on the doll because it feels like
it's it's working already and it's works
for so so long for so well for so long
that I didn't want to do too much to
anything too drastic with it and that's
what's great about that doll why she
doesn't get up and move around or
anything that you can really just cut to
her and hold on her and it's it gets
people on the edge of their seat which
is so great that is so fascinating it's
it's an inanimate object that just sits
there so it's like at the very beginning
I'm like well how do you make it scary
for a whole movie and there's just
learned that pretty early on too like
the audience it's great when you're
watching and you're you know we show
these movies of family and friends and
stuff and whenever you cut to that doll
there's always that little nervous
whisper in the audience that's so good
it's just you know you don't want to
lean on the too much but it's it's it's
a great it's a it's a good how do we get
them on their toes soon well you also
you get to you get to like play with so
much in this movie because of the
context of bringing the whole room alive
right so how did you decide how much
Annabelle you want in the Annabelle film
versus all these other wonderful things
that I will not spoil that are in it and
you know striking the right balance so
it still feels like an Annabelle film
but you're still playing with you know
sort of every color in the cran box you
have at your disposal
yeah and that was a real challenge it
was that was looking at it from an
editorial standpoint you know in when we
script it out because I had many drafts
where it's like you know a lot more
artifacts and stuff but then it just
becomes you know the waters start to
become muddied and you don't quite know
where you're which one you're supposed
to be scared of if that makes sense
because there's so much there you know
and I didn't want it to feel like that
and and I'm just expositionally like
you're just like oh my god like here's
another scary story about this thing so
I knew I wanted to treat Annabelle's we
doing a lot of these movies just kind of
she's like the orchestrator she's like
the the maestro the conductor of all
this sort of mayhem she she is I'm like
Chucky or somebody who and I love Chucky
you know gets up and does his own dirty
work
Annabelle sometimes has other people do
it for her other entities are spirits
and I think she does that in this movie
too so I wanted her to be sort of you
know have the you know sort of the main
the main presence but you know really I
thought this would be a great
opportunity to explore those other
artifacts and and then it just came down
to me going back to this you know with
the war in archives and the Case Files
and just you know or just what hey what
do I think would be cool to playing
around with sort of mentally doing a
tour of the the of the artifact room
that James had set up in the contouring
one just to see what I really responded
to and what I think could be could be
fun so so it was it but it was a ongoing
conversation with myself about what not
to include because it was there's there
is a lot you can include there's a lot
of stuff the stuff of the show
so yeah there's had a very vivid flash
as you were describing that for whatever
reason that we need an Annabelle cartoon
series like a classically hand-drawn
cartoon series and it should just be
Annabelle and friends right yeah that
sounds great
I feel like there is something to be
said for hard that bridges the gap for
all generations so that would be to
prime the kids for when they get older
and they can watch future installments
that would be great yeah and you get to
embrace your animation there you go you
know I just lost down on the Super
Friends a Super Friends sell over the
weekend that hairatan auction yeah
because were gone that site was it was
completely under bed probably get this
for a couple thousand dollars it's way
too off it is a major problem for me and
surprise I don't own anything from the
conjuring saying I went nuts I'll never
forget being on that set to back like
what was it like 2012 or 2011 and it was
called the Warren files at the time and
like we saw a viewer of filming in the
basement and it's just it's crazy to
think about that and how important that
movie is for this entire genre
personally now I love it yeah it's great
but back to the I do yeah like like the
you talking about bidding on things like
the big props is an outrage addiction
for me and it's become a little bit of a
problem in my life no no I know and I
literally wrote into the script like you
know that the the Remington typewriter
comes alive and starts typing miss me
you know and I literally wrote I will be
stealing this after things I'm taking
home from the set because I guess it's
right you know it's addressed as a man I
got a take oh I want to take some
ownership for these things and yes I was
able to take a few things home and and
put them on the shelves I don't
understand how anybody kind of holds
back when they make a movie and they
don't take something they put the fear
of God you know so it's like so that's
like stories and like actors who do and
people are like you're gonna have to
give that back sure but so I took the I
did take the doll home on the last day
and I was like but I didn't I wasn't
sure I was gonna do it but anyway like
someone told me like what do you come to
your house and actually take the doll
back two days later they came to my
house and took the doll two days that's
right I was joking at the event that
they should send you a gilded Annabelle
doll if you hit a certain box you are
also sitting at the table that is the
self-proclaimed McKenna grace bag that's
right we think she is like the greatest
thing in the entire world what is it
like working with her I assume it comes
across like she is just a young pro I
forgot to tell you she gave me a sticker
at the junket she was giving everyone
stickers is the sweetest thing ever she
would every other day I think not every
other day but she would she would make
me stings all the time though I still
carry around with me am i having my
backpack and all that stuff but she
would just come in with these crafts
that she made and it was just the best
worse it was so touching but she is one
of them she is we've we've really become
great friends and friends with her
family and
she's so thoughtful and she's such a fan
of genre like she you know The Shining
is like her favorite movie she loves she
lives in Brie's horror she loves it and
you know it was just you know you always
get nervous when you you're working with
with with young actors because you never
know how they're gonna but she's she's
so on it that it was really we had such
a great shorthand it was not much I
really had to do to coax a great
performance out of her she's just she is
next-level when it comes to when it
comes to talent you know Judy Warren has
this otherworldly being uh you know
about her and you know McKenna is that
same way so it's it's just you know it's
it well for the character I guess you
guys you know dipped your toes in the
Hillhouse world twice now now I'm just
remembering Lula Wilson is in creation
that's a fair point
they stole it from you guys now we need
Gabriel Bateman from child's play in a
future conjuring universe movie because
he I mean he worked with David he's
fantastic the baby and family is
something else oh yeah so you you are
obviously in this position to learn from
some incredible filmmakers having worked
with one you worked with miss Yeti on it
do you have you seen like a shared trait
in what makes great filmmakers or is it
two individual share trades I think the
first thing that comes to mind is that
these guys you know why they have a love
of movies they love making movies too
they love that creative process I also
find them to be you know the all the
directors are the filmmakers I've worked
with they are also great collaborators
there no there no one like I got you
know this is this is all on me it's it's
they're very they surround themselves
with a great team you know but
they understand that and embrace it and
are aware of that as opposed to this is
this is only good because it's I'm the
only one who's doing anything here but I
think they and I also think they're very
very I mean this these are all boring
answers there's no there's no sleep but
they have a very very strong work work
ethic as well sure which is I think
really important I know it seems so base
and silly but there's a lot of people
out there who do not want to put in the
work to get to where these people are I
see that in writers too I tell writers
who are starting out like you know the
95 percent of your of your mission is
just to finish the script because that
really does take away 95% of the
competition because there's so many
writers out there who have unfinished
drafts in their drawer and oh if I only
had more time they'll find the time you
got to find the time and finish it so
but these guys I think they just have a
really strong vision really strong work
ethic and they love the process of
making movies and that's from soup to
nuts I mean every every part of the
process they really enjoy and they're
always learning and they're always bring
something to the table and yeah I mean
they're just genuine there it was it's
just been it's just an a boss to be able
to to be around people like that and
soak it up again I still feel like
someone's gonna want some sort of
contest in there you know there's a
ticking clock there but did you find
that you also loved directing and
filmmaking I really did and you know
again it comes down to you know I could
see how it could be a miserable
experience if you're working with people
that you do not like and you do not
enjoy and you do not respect I can see
how it would be a just a slog to get
through but that was not the case for me
I had the you know that I'd worked with
a lot of the other people on the other
movies but I hadn't worked with the cast
yet you know McKenna Madison Katie so
they were they were really the question
marks but as soon as they walked in the
room soon as I sat down with them they
were no longer question marks I mean
they became really answers for me they
they they they were so thoughtful
you know just great storytellers in
their own right and we're always quick
to come up with suggestions and hey
let's try this let's try that
and that was part
you know going back to the you know just
finding out what my process was it's
really seeing a scene and putting in a
lot his feet and like let's play around
let's see what works let's see what
doesn't and that was a it's a lot of fun
to not have the the stress of like I got
a know-it-all on the first take you know
it's there's a process of discovery
there and they were all willing
participants of going through that sort
of activating like what the final you
know what the what the final scene is
going to be which was a lot of fun it
really what felt like you I was making a
movie with a bunch of my friends you
could feel that I mean that's part of
the reason why I love the rise of social
media like I know there's some negative
elements of it but when filmmakers and
cast members they share some of their
experience and you kind of get to
associate with a movie that you love and
that way too it's like I feel that same
way about the it cast and crew yeah
there's something about it that makes
those movies mean more to me because
they've kind of made me feel a part of
it in a weird way right right right and
there's a strong connection yeah it yeah
I mean everybody is so super tight still
they're all they all get a little get
together when they can get together I
mean it's just a really and I think that
has a lot to do with the machetes and
how they you know what they how they're
just how it is being on set and all that
stuff and yeah I think I think if it
feels like it's a painting or like work
I think it's like it's hard it's I think
it's I think that can show I think if
you can have a sense of fun and
playfulness I think that can really come
through and in the final product so that
was yeah I mean that was something that
was important to me is there any part of
either this film or any of your other
writing where you kind of got bogged
down in that mindset where you couldn't
kind of be playful and crack through
something but then all of a sudden you
realize like you got it and how I guess
did you motivate yourself to get there
oh my I mean every time I you know every
time I sort of script it's that blank
page that first trying to figure out
what that first scene is or what that's
that's the toughest part for me it's
just getting started and yeah you feel
like I forgot everything like you know
what I mean like well I got a reteach my
you know I got a go back to you know
whatever go how do I format again you
know it just feels like I'm a beginner
all over again each time I start with a
new script so that's the that's yeah so
you know yeah I do get bogged down and
all that stuff but then you hit that you
know you just hit that
right yeah you something clicks and you
can be a little bit more free and
playfulness and that's where the good
stuff comes in the pages start to come
and come and then yeah then you get
slowed down again and all this stuff but
you know what I've learned now is you
know I don't have to write a move I
don't have to write a script from
beginning middle and end I can jump
around I can go if I'm stuck on
something I can well I know I know how
it's gonna end let me start working on
the ending or you know I can go back to
it seen that I skipped earlier or
something like that so I've allowed
myself to free myself up for not having
to be like I don't have to be go from
page 17 to 18 19 I can go to page 17 237
if I want to and just you know and that
helps me you know get through all those
like when you're just lost and like the
you know what am I gonna do I love that
every single time I write a written
review rather than one of our videos I
always write the whole thing first and
then write the intro paragraph after oh
well every single time because the intro
is the toughest part yeah and something
about having written the rest of it
gives me like a better understanding of
like that that overview paragraph the
primer paragraph needs to be I always
think that I'm writing the intro and
then I'm like oh no that's actually what
happens yeah yeah the beginning is so
it's so so tough and I will often skip
the beginning as well and just jump
right into you know somewhere in the
first act that just makes sense because
because yeah you can get you can lose a
lot of time just trying to go what's the
perfect first thing do you think the
beginning or the ending is harder
I think endings are really really tough
yeah they're really really hard
especially in horror and because we're
big Stephen King fans we have to go
there I'm wondering what do you find to
be the most difficult thing about
adapting a Stephen King novel not
[ __ ] it up yeah I do I don't want to
screw it up I mean these things have
worked as well as they have for such a
long time so it's not like I'm gonna
come in and go oh he got it wrong all
those years ago I'm finally if I figured
out how to fix it so it's it's again
going back to this artifact stuff it's
much it's very much an editorial process
going like is I can't fit it all and
it's all great well you know right now
I'm writing Salem's Lot so it's just one
of those and you know so it's one of
those things I want to be as faithful as
I can but there's a lot of characters a
lot of stuff and you got to go okay what
can i what can I do without that people
aren't going to miss and that's
oftentimes with you know working with my
producers and the executives of a new
line like I will try things out not tell
them that I'm losing something and
they're all fans of King as well so they
all know it front to back so I'll take
something out if no one pings on if no
one goes hey where did that I know like
oh maybe that's something we can do
without but it really is like trying to
you know just get to them just get to
the meat of it but it is it's a really
great experience and adapting someone
like him you know why Salem's Lot
because there's well there's yeah what I
mean why not is a good response but
there are so many Stephen King novels
out there that are well worth adapting
I'm just curious why especially when we
do have the the miniseries for that one
like why why now for that one well we
had the miniseries for it well and and I
would dare say that's probably more
iconic of miniseries then than the same
was a lot miniseries that David Saul and
then they had one in a separate related
that they had another one that was and
by the way I loved a miniseries yeah and
then they had the other one a couple you
know 20 years back or so but it has not
had the big screen president it had not
has not had the cinematic treatment that
like say that it has and I personally
have not seen a really great terrifying
vampire movie in a very very long time
so it feels to me like it's it's the the
time is right for that question sure for
you how deep does your Stephen King lore
obsession role now that you're playing
with not just it which has some of the
most insane lore but also the
connections between Salem's Lot and The
Dark Tower series are rather
intimidating so they are intimidating
but
so very very exciting yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean that's that's so I know
that I you know I know the I know the
the stories around the Sandlot
that's what makes me excited about the
movie - I think we can tell whole host
of stories if you know you know God
Wayne the first one works out but but
yeah I go I can get pretty deep in there
but I mean there's you know I think I
was telling someone earlier one of my
one of my strengths and weaknesses are
that I have a terrible memory so it's
not like so what I'm sitting down and
writing something I'm not going
so listen why I would love to have an
encyclopedic knowledge of this stuff so
I could sit there and teach a class or
whatever but what I'm sitting down the
right I'm also not going like oh well
they already did that in such a such a
movie which I think which I think stops
a lot of people from writing a lot of
times because like I can't do that even
though you can take the same idea we can
all take the same idea and it's gonna
turn out three different three times
over but so so yeah I can get there
pretty deep with with this with the King
war but there are there are a lot of
people online that I would not want to
go toe-to-toe
it's actually one of the most
intimidating mythologies I think to try
to process and if you should ever be
hired for a freelance piece I have it
hasn't published and I'll probably have
to tack it to my wall in charge it's
it's particularly about it and Pennywise
and trying to make any kind of sense out
of that but then as soon as I write
about that I have to mention the Dark
Tower stuff because there's so much that
it's like not confirmed connected but
tandon yeah that's a lot I mean I know
you can't talk about it like at all so
I'm not gonna press on that but all I'll
say is if you like the the first one
you're gonna yeah you're very very much
like the second one are you happy with
that steam your big big fans very dense
I have a huge compliment to pay you
which is that having you seen
Annabelle's comes home
I don't think you get enough credit for
what works in that movie because of the
development process and because there
was a pre-existing script and I saw an
Annabel comes home so many of the things
that people love about it well thank you
so much I really appreciate you saying
appreciate you saying that
I don't I'm just I was very very happy
to be involved in that one and that was
a great experience working you know it's
where I've you know it was yeah just to
be that's where I you know I met them
you see at ease and was able to start a
working relationship with them and but
yeah it's very nice of you to say but
yeah it's just it's just I'm just happy
to be a part of it I don't really thank
you so much they're a very special duo
to actually I wanted to ask you in the
horror genre whether it is like a new
piece of tech a new style a new trend
another filmmaker out there is there
anybody who's doing something for the
industry right now in the horror genre
that really excites you for the future
oh my god I don't know I'd have to turn
I don't know I mean I introduce turn
that question around to you uh you know
I read a lot of I don't know I read a
lot of novels I read a lot of I'm trying
to think what would you say what was it
now one of the answers that are oh it's
always just on the top of my my brain is
someone like Octavia Spencer who I mean
I'm just thinking genre because of MA
someone who has some some star power and
some weight to swing around and they're
using that to make films for for
themselves to give new opportunities to
people who hadn't had them before so I
would say someone someone like art I
think it's a great answer yeah I think
that's a fantastic answer what was the
other thing I was thinking of oh you
know I know nothing about it but I this
is this idea that Spielberg is doing
something where you can only watch it at
night just what do you want interesting
answer or interesting idea or
interesting I don't like that idea at ha
I'm trying to write interesting
in some weather yeah yeah I mean I we're
here to hear what you think I just think
that Steven Spielberg has long not
necessarily understood how people like
to take in material at home when his
fight against DVDs and stuff and sure I
think that asking people to tune in
specifically only @midnight is not gonna
be awesome for numbers i well i'm
thinking beyond the numbers i but i love
the idea that it makes it feel a little
bit like an event because now and
nowadays i find something there's you
know with social media and things
everything feels so familiar and so
readily accessible it's hard to there's
there's very few things that I feel like
events anymore you know and so something
like that makes it feel like everybody's
gonna gather around at midnight and
watch this thing and everyone might be
three people but it's still it's still
something that excites me because I find
it to be a little like I think we're so
oversaturate and they're so everything
so accessible and like you know I spend
more time searching for something on
Netflix and I do watching something on
Netflix you know things like that were
just like let me see you know I'll watch
20 minutes or something or there but
something like that makes it feel like a
real you know it could be a real event I
don't know whether or not thanks it's
just it's cool I have no idea what it's
gonna work or not but I like that it's
being tried it's almost like a blending
of the old and the new it's like the new
is watch anytime you want on any device
you want whereas you know originally
when it was broadcast TV we used to sit
down at like 8 o'clock on a Thursday to
watch the hottest new show this is
almost like a mixture of those two yeah
it's just it's just a control aspect of
it I find I'm really bummed out by you
know III understand how you know shows
are now being you know you we can watch
it all at once we're getting all the
episodes released but I really do feel
like that takes some of the conversation
away because I can say oh did you watch
this you know did you watch the series
and you're like yeah no no I finished it
last night and goes no no don't tell me
you know me as opposed to something
where it's like we all have to watch it
at the same time and then we're all part
of the conversation I was hoping you
know I you know I liked like swamp thing
we did is is being released week to week
and and you know I was kind of hoping
that would be kind of a throwback to
people just getting now getting caught
up and being a part of the conversation
and whatever whether it's it is or not I
don't know but
I like that old-school vibe of it of
just being like the water cooler
conversation like we don't have that
much anymore
I mean Game of Thrones was like that's
part of why I think it was such a call I
know I haven't seen the last season
don't know I know it's it's a no I'm Way
behind on that I know what what are you
caught up on now whether it's a show
just a series of movies a book anything
at all that you would want our viewers
to watch read listen to anything at all
I think I'm late to the party on this
one but I just two days ago finished the
first seasons on Cobra Kai which is I
thought was just perfect from start to
finish how do you guys see it yes
absolutely it was you know sometimes I
watch something a million and one
reasons why I thought that that was not
going to work and they exceeded my
expectations in so many ways it's like I
got to look I've had such a you know
it's been a very stressful anxious time
and to be able to rely on that to just
get me like it just it's just all this
waves of nostalgia and they're so
they're so great in it I mean there's
really just just I think you can just
come into a cold and still see what a
well-executed show that is so I have not
started season two yet but I can't wait
to start season two but that is
something that I'm gonna be singing its
praises for some good original content
you should watch impulse also like
impulse didn't get nearly as much love
as instead of it was kind of the the
sequel ish series to jumper oh so she's
not really connected to jumper it's its
own thing with like new really rich
interesting layered characters I was
very into it okay cool oh yeah
definitely definitely check that out no
Cobra Kai really opened my eyes up to
what really I mean I don't know if I
just watched any other YouTube things
but I'm kind of into it I think that's
like their first breakout hit I think so
yeah yeah there's don't ask burning
question number two of course as we wind
down yeah okay yes it's our favorite
question do you have any pet
that's right I do have I have a I have a
chug PO I have a terrier - what like a
chihuahua rizz we learn about so many
different dogs here with dog names a
chuck is a chihuahua pug okay so he's
got a big fat body a little wet but he
is yeah all my pets are one of my
reasons for being and then we just
recently my daughter turned six and for
her birthday we got a we went in for a
hamster we came out with a guinea pig so
we have a guinea pig named bagel that
III I never really thought cared much
for guinea pigs but wow they have like
personalities and stuff and like they
like to be held didn't you watch flea
bag dig yeah has been a welcome addition
to our family dogs are for people for
sure no present company excluded
surprising how many were we're not
surprising it just everybody that we
bring in for this seems to freaking love
animals no you know I you know I'm the
first but I love people showing me
pictures of their pets I love showing my
dogs I've so many photos of them just
sleeping or whatever but also they're
the ones with my mom's 3:00 in the
morning and writing and they're the ones
sort of laying down just play around
with her a little bit I'm telling you
it's something about what I was saying
earlier there's something there's
something about the horror community we
may call this like twisted stuff by
we're all like super sweet like pet
loving people I'm glad we got to that
question we do have to wrap this up and
I want to let you guys know we are
wrapping this episode early because when
you see Annabelle comes home you're
gonna get to see a conversation with
Gary and Haley about all the ins and
outs the spoilery fun stuff so that is a
wrap on this episode of the witching
hour so before we say goodbye some
social media shoutouts I mean do you
have like a website or anyway
you want to direct people know in that
guide to the theater Annabel comes home
on June 26
chuck it out nationwide enjoy and then
tell us what you guys think hailey where
can everyone find you on the Internet
you can find me on Twitter at hailey
fetch and on instagram at haystack my
group and I am at Pea Nemiroff on
twitter and instagram thank you so much
for thank you guys so much appreciation
to you very much thanks to everybody out
there watching you have officially
survived the witching hour
you